VISIT JAB MEANT DOT COM.
>> AND NOW WE ESCAPED TO
MEXICO. HOME AND I'M JEALOUS
ROCKY, SHE STOPPED BY BYBYBYBYA
POP-UP BAR EXPERIENCE THAT
WILL TURN YOUR WALK DOWN THE
STRIP INTO A FIESTA.
>> WELCOME TO THE VILLA ONE
TEQUILA GARDENGA, IT'S A
BEAUTIFUL ISLAND, GAME RIGHT
HERE ON THE STEPS OF CITY TELL
US ABOUT THE 2 VERY SPECIAL
OWNERS OF THIS STARTED.
>> SO WE HAVE DONATE BEEN JOB
BARBADOS FOR THE VILLA ONE
TEQUILA IS THEIR FIRST POP-UP
RIGHT HERE IN LAS VEGAS AND
WHERE IS IT LOCATED EXACTLY
TELL PEOPLE HOW THEY CAN HOW
THEY CAN FIND YOU SO WE'RE
LOOKING AT G RIGHG T HERE REON
HARM AND RETAIL CORNER
RECOMMEND PARKING AT THE TAKES
MAKE SOMETHING ABOUT CROSS THE
IDGE EASY TRAVEL EXPERT BEN,
YOU THAT YOU GUYS DO MAKE IT
REALLY EASY FOR US BECAUSE AS
YOU CAN SEE JUST JUWAJULK JUUP
ORDER YOUR DRINK. MEXICAN
EXPERIENCE RIGHT HERE ON THIS
TRIP I LOVE IT AND YOU DESIGN
PART OF THE MENU. SO WHAT KIND
OF DRINKS ARE WE HAVING AT IT
BELO W           BELOW GARDW E
HAVE THE BECOME BIG O YES,
SUPER REFRESHING FOR THE HOT
HERE AND THEY GET THAT AND
THEN WE HAVE THE CANNERY TELLS
THAT SHEA FROM MEXICO LIKE THE
WHOLE EXPERIENCE THE JUICES
AND IS THIS THE LIME ROCK
OKAY, SO THIS IS AN EXPERIENCE
RIGHT HERE SO LET'S GET INTO
IT THE CANCER EAT SO HOW DO WE
MAKE THIS KIND OF DRINK. SO
WE'RE GOING TO START BY
SQUEEZY. WELL MY GOSH FOR REST
SOME HOW LONG DOES IT TAKE TO
MAKE BECAUSE I'M SURE YOU HAVE
A
OR NO I BAD SO YEAH LIKE
LITERALLY A FEW GET INTO THE
BALL YET PEOPLE REALLY LOVE
LIKE WATCHING MADE IT SO
>> YOU KNOW THIS REALLY
REFRESHING. WHAT HAVE PEOPLE
BEEN SAYING AS THEY COME UP IN
DISCOVERY SAYS WELL THEY
DISLIKED YOU KNOW THEY HAVEN'T
EXPERIENCED ANYTHING LIKE YOU
KNOW.
>> HERE FROM ALL AROUND THE
WORLD YEAH, THIS IS NOT WHAT
THEY EXPECTED. THIS IS A GREAT
LOCATION FOR IT. WE HAVE ONE
OF THE DRINKS THAT ROAD, THE
JUICES THAT MAKE THIS UP AND
SO WE HAVE FRESH SQUEEZED
ORANGE TOO. THAT'S WHERE A
WHITE T-SHIRT WITH THE WIFE
KEEP YOU NICE AND COOL IT'S
3RD A LITTLE BIT. AND THEN OF
COURSE, THE MAIN INGREDIENT IS
SICK YOU THE BILL ONCE A KEY
LED JONAS OF THE JONAS
BROTHERS BASHING I WHAT MAKES
A SUPER SPECIAL. OVERALL IT
LIKE TO TAKE IT'S SWEETER THAN
MOST THE KEELAN KNOW IT'S EASY
FOR SIPPING OKAY, OKAY THAT'S
GOOD. THEY WERE JUST GOING
ABOUT GRAPEFRUIT JUICE WHICH
BRINGS IT ALL TOGETHER
>> WELL OKAY AND LAST BUT NOT
LOOK AT THIS YOU GUYS
ALL MY GOSMYH. MYMYMYMYMYMYWE'R
PUT IT IN VERY SPECIAL
AUTHENTIC. THAT YOU CAN
ACTUALLY TAKE WITH YOU AS YOU
WALK THE STRAIGHT. YEARS. OH
MY GOSH AND HE'S ESPECIALLY
IMPORTANT SO THEY'RE HANDMADE
AND CRAFT
>> SUPER TASTY AND OF COURSE
THE GARNISH RIGHT. TOP IT ALL
OFF. AND IT WAS GREAT ROOM.
AND CHEERS TO BELOW ONE TO Q A
FUTURE OF THIS PLACE I HEAR
YOU GUYS ARE GROWING SO WE ARE
GROWING OUR FIRST LOCATION
WE'RE GOING WE'RE EXPANDING TO
SAN DIEGO, YORK, MIAMI AND
WE'RE ALSO EXPANDING RIGHT
HERE AND ARE SO GOT TO FOLLOW
YOU GUYS AT VILLA ONE TEQUILA
GARDENS YET TO BE
>> WHAT'S HERE'S THE U 2 YEAR